mr. Lewis thank you for coming in with
your associates I know this is hard to
hear but we need to make some serious
decisions about your mother's health
let's be honest she is getting on in
years oh yeah okay I see how it is
I see how well yo mama so Oh her last
name is asaurus no mr. Lewis it wasn't
an insult
I was just saying that your mother's
condition is deteriorating because she's
getting older Oh see that's cold though
that's a cold one okay okay I see how it
is yeah yo mama so old in her history
class they just wrote down what they was
doing insult contest not only is your
mother elderly but also her ability to
walk is currently being affected by her
weight Oh see okay it just got real no
I'm not insulting her I'm trying to tell
you yo mama is so fat we should go to
the movie theater [ __ ] sitting next to
every way your mother needs to manage
her weight or there can be some real
problems so fat she need a latitude and
longitude double to fight her old ass
[Applause]
who's the doctor mr. Lewis
I am and it's my job to make sure that
your mother is getting the care that she
needs we are talking about the woman who
took care of you your whole life the
least you can do is take care of her and
her old age and take this seriously I'm
sorry I'm sorry then they lost my temper
no really doctor I guess I was just
joking around because I know her
condition is really serious
and I don't know I guess humor is the
only way I could really deal with it oh
I just know that she says so many times
she doesn't want anything invasive died
billion I was not aware of that that
that's interesting because she did not
mention that to me in our previous
conversation because it was difficult to
hear her with in her mouth
snap mr. Lewis oh snap
now let's talk about the procedure
you